let's start today with joe biden's first
state of the union address many of you
wrote to me you said david i remember in
2021 joe biden gave a state of the union
address yes he basically did except in a
president's first year in office
that first joint address to the house
and senate is not called a state of the
union address so this was the first
state of the union address by name
but the second one in spirit i guess we
would say overall
it was okay it was okay i mean i'll give
you kind of my more
wrap-up overall review after we look at
some clips but i think joe biden sort of
struck the right note and tone overall
and in particular with ukraine russia
that was probably the strongest part and
he opened with that there was a bunch in
the middle that was very so so and a lot
of kind of vague throwing out things
he's going to do
which will obviously never see the light
of day with absolutely no explanation as
to how some of those things would even
be possible and we will get to that but
overall this is you have to remember
this is a particularly weaponized
republican party whose goal is just stop
biden at any opportunity stop just don't
let him do anything and given that
context it is difficult to put together
a speech that uh republicans in any any
real way are going to be satisfied by
but let's just get right into it uh joe
biden opening up with a statement of
solidarity with ukraine
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead he met with a mall a wall of
strength he never anticipated or
imagined he met ukrainian people
so the tone here was the right tone and
again
he started strong and this was really
one of the better parts of the speech
continuing on to talk about
new restrictions sanctions limitations
on russia and russian oligarchs and
again also played very well with the
crowd tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean it
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you ill-begotten gains
and tonight
i'm announcing that we will join our
allies in closing off american airspace
to all russian flights further isolating
russia and adding additional squeeze on
their economy
so more restrictions and those well
received and the restrictions make sense
the only caveat is we we do want to make
sure that all americans that are in
russia can get home obviously the
signals to those in ukraine for a while
have been get out
but we want to make sure that americans
in russia can get home but all popular
sensible things to be doing um and uh
again
republicans basically clapping for just
about everything joe biden said on the
issue of russia ukraine united states
and our allies will defend every inch of
territory that is nato territory for the
full force of our collective power every
single inch
okay so that stuff very strong and very
popular with the entire crowd and then
it became a more typical state of the
union address republicans for example
booing
when joe biden correctly points out
donald trump's tax cuts
disproportionately benefited the rich
they did and republicans boo either
because they don't believe it or because
they don't like that it's being pointed
out
unlike the 2 trillion tax cut passed in
the previous administration
that benefited the top one percent of
americans the american rescue plan
[Music]
[Applause]
the american rescue plan
helped working people and left no one
behind
so a bit of a strange false start there
from chuck schumer but uh the
republicans booing joe biden's comment
about who benefited from donald trump's
tax cuts although what joe biden said
was perfectly accurate at then at an
almost immediately uh subsequent point
joe biden talks about what has been
record job growth under the biden
administration and of course it is true
and we can flesh that out further by
talking about this sort of unique
coveted recovery period in which joe
biden started his uh uh presidency
needless to say at one point the camera
points to mitch mcconnell and
mcconnell looks like he had some bad
clams uh before the event upon hearing
about record job growth
we created jobs lots of jobs in fact our
economy created over
6.5 million new jobs just last year
more jobs
in one year
than ever before in the history of the
united states of america
the economy grew at a rate of 5.7 last
year the strongest growth rate in 40
years
and the first step in bringing
fundamental change to our economy that
hasn't worked for working people in this
nation for too long
for the past 40 years and there's mitch
mcconnell who just looks like something
was wrong with the muscles if you know
what i mean at dinner beforehand um then
joe biden started getting into some of
sort of the the general policy ideas and
a lot of them made for ok rhetoric but
i'm going to be honest with you guys a
lot of these are basically
impossibilities let's listen to the
first one
that means make more cars than
semiconductors in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america
more jobs where you can earn a good
living in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america
look
economist
you know
i think this is one of those things
where it
this is the epitome of the absurdity of
american politics
republicans who say they're all about
build and buy american are mostly just
sitting
after joe biden says we're gonna build
and buy americans so first of all i
thought republicans wanted that and then
all of a sudden they're sitting down and
it's just political trash
at the same time we have an economy
based on not building american and what
i mean by that is
decades ago the decision was made
implicitly it's not that someone one day
said let's structure our entire economy
on cheap stuff from china and other
countries nobody said that
but through cumulative decisions about
labor and about outsourcing and about
trade
the collective implicit decision was
made we would rather pay less for stuff
but get it from places like china and to
do the build and buy american thing that
joe biden is talking about
it would raise prices on those things in
the united states it just it would and
it would take at minimum eight to ten
years to start making a lot of those
changes so i'm not saying it's good or
bad i'm pointing out
the absurdity of a president saying
it's going to be great when we do this
thing which all of us over the last 40
years have decided not to do we've
actually done the opposite through our
trade and other regulations and
agreements
but also it's something republicans
claim to want but they don't cheer when
joe biden says it it's like the those 25
seconds are the epitome of everything
that's sort of broken with american
politics now the most vile moment of the
entire speech and we will focus in on
this more later was when joe biden was
talking
about his son beau who died of cancer
and lauren bobert yells out
disgustingly you've been there
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
these burn pits that incinerate waste
the waste of war
medical
and hazards material jet fuel and so
much more
and they come home
many of the world's fittest and best
trained warriors in the world
never the same
headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
one of those so uh
one of those soldiers was my son major
yeah that was um that was lauren
beaubert and we're gonna talk about that
a little later one of the most the most
disgusting moment i ever remember from
any state of the union um joe biden then
talking about corporations and the
wealthy paying higher taxes and
elizabeth warren liked it looking to
punish anybody
but let's make corporations and wealthy
americans start paying their fair share
look
last year
last year
so elizabeth warren liking that one
understandingly understandably then a
sort of kind of like a muted we've done
pretty well and are ready to kind of
start moving on from kovid not like the
huge mission accomplished but sort of
one for more than two years covet has
impacted every decision in our lives
and the life of this nation
and i know you're tired frustrated and
exhausted
that doesn't even count
close to a million people who sit at a
dining room table or a kitchen table
look at an empty chair
because they lost somebody
but i also know this
because of the progress we've made
because of your resilience
and the tools that we have been provided
by this congress
tonight i can say we're moving forward
safely
back to no
more normal routines
we've reached a new moment in the fight
against covet 19. so a sort of soft
victory declaration which i think is is
okay it's what was expected and it's
it's basically
uh
warranted by the numbers that we are
seeing at another point joe biden
talking about the importance of
funding police funding police all agree
the answer is not to defund the police
is to fund the police
so some on the left uh taking that as a
direct attack on the progressive
movement but the truth is the the
majority of the progressive movement
doesn't actually want to defund the
police we want to fix the police and and
uh that's that's the reality um lastly
joe biden again finishing strong on the
topic of ukraine
and go get em go get em the final line
of the night
i've come to report on the state of the
nation the state of the union and my
report is this
the state of the union is strong because
you the american people are strong
we are stronger today
we are stronger today than we were a
year ago
and we'll be stronger a year from now
than we are today
this is our moment
to meet and overcome the challenges of
our time and we will
as one people one america the united
states of america
god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
thank you
go get him
go get him seemingly uh apparently
related to vladimir putin so okay my my
honest rating if i just say this is what
what it was with normal standards right
i mean trump really threw off our
barometer but with normal standards this
was probably a b
uh the opening ukraine section was good
it was the right tone the entire speech
was probably the right tone and energy
there were endless disjointed
transitions that were extraordinarily
abrupt a lot of very vague ideas thrown
out at one point joe biden saying we're
gonna crack down on people charging
customers too much for for things
like wait are you suggesting price
controls like that's a really big deal
what are you talking about are you
proposing legislation
absolutely no idea and i understand it's
a state of the union you don't lay out
everything in detail but there were so
many of those things thrown out which
are obviously never going to see the
light of day so i would give it a b
overall with many elements that were
what was needed
given the situation in ukraine and
russia not made easier overall by the
fact that the republican party has
become a parody of itself so that's my
thought let's now talk about the most
vile moment ever in a state of the union
address
i want to introduce you to emmy the
world's first instant ramen that is low
carb
high protein and 100
plant based
each serving of imi is packed with 21
grams of protein
19 grams of fiber has only five net
carbs works for keto diets and 35
percent less sodium than traditional
ramen brands i've been making it at home
just like any instant ramen it's ready
in just a few minutes you can use the
microwave you can use the stovetop you
really can't beat the convenience but
with imme you can feel good about the
ramen you're eating because of all the
fiber the lower sodium and it is
plant-based which i love even though i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but the best
part is
it's so well packaged it comes in
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp
black garlic chicken the taste and the
quality of the ingredients really sets
it apart from any other instant ramen
i've had and emmy is giving my audience
five dollars off a variety pack when you
go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is down below